doctors that are in demand realize that
working with insurance companies will
yield a lower profit in working with
individuals who have cash who want
on-demand service so they leave the
insurance game and they say I'm only
going to accept cash payments from now
on that way they know exactly what
they're getting paid they don't have to
argue with insurers and as a result they
are more financially successful than
doctors who accept Insurance that's what
happened to me when I did a skin checkup
I had a mole and WebMD said it was basal
cell I wanted to get it checked out but
the wait was two months to get in or I
just pay 250 out of pocket I go to the
person down the street and I got in the
next morning